my mom thought it was crazy when I told
her I was into underwater hockey and she
continues to think I'm crazy when I show
up with black eyes but she's also my
biggest fan one of other world
championships my name is tre ullberg and
I'm the captain of the u.s. women's
underwater hockey team
so underwater hockey's played six on six
and we're not wearing tanks just spins a
mask and snorkel the puck is weighted
and sits on the bottom of the pool and
players use short one-handed stick to
play the puck
unlike ice hockey there's no goalie and
underwater hockey and the snorkel helps
you watch the play while you're
recovering on the surface but otherwise
you're holding your breaths when you're
actually involved in the play
we take underwater hockey very seriously
the u.s. women's national team competed
in the World Championships there held
every two years and they bring in about
25 different countries to compete to be
the best of the best it really is the
ultimate team sport because there's no
package that can just do everything for
your team eventually that person's going
to have to come up to breathe and you
have to have a teammate there to take
your place if I'm about to score and I'm
running out of air and then a freaking
score we see people coming to underwater
hockey both from swimming backgrounds
and from ice hockey backgrounds we
struggles from the fact that most people
in the United States don't grow up
playing it people don't grow up holding
their breath and trying to kick hard
underwater they grew up playing soccer
and playing basketball
there's no no money in underwater hockey
so we're absolutely doing it for the
love of sport I love underwater hockey
it's so elegant being underwater it is
just a beautiful thing I feel like some
really gorgeous sea creature when I play